en el vídeo anterior vimos o que quizás
sería la economía más sencilla y ni
siquiera está claro si esta economía es
posible esta economía de solamente una
persona pero para hacerlo más análogo al
mundo real donde tenemos compañías y
dueños de las compañías en esta isla
aquí este amigo puso una compañía y
esencialmente arriendo todos los
factores de producción a esa compañía
incluyendo su mano de obra pues ésta era
su salario y bueno después compró todos
los bienes y servicios que necesitaba de
la misma compañía haciendo esto de
comprar los bienes y servicios de la
compañía hace que sus gastos sean
ingresos para la compañía y los ingresos
de la compañía se convierten en gastos y
ganancias para la misma y de esta manera
tenemos que lo que no se usará de gastos
en los ingresos terminaba siendo
ganancia y esas ganancias regresaban al
ocupante de la casa al dueño de la
compañía le regresaban esas ganancias
como ingresos y después hablábamos de
cómo me diríamos la actividad económica
en esta isla es decir cómo medir el
producto interno bruto
podremos medirlo en múltiples maneras
podríamos medirlo mientras se van de la
mano
puedes verlo como los gastos totales o
mientras se aproxima a la compañía que
es lo mismo que los ingresos totales
para la compañía que estamos manejando
para esta esta economía sencilla donde
esos ingresos son lo mismo que el total
de los gastos más la ganancia de esa
compañía y eso es lo mismo que los
ingresos para el dueño lo voy a poner
aquí abajo la manera lo que en la que lo
vimos en el ejemplo sencillo el pib era
igual a los gastos del dueño lo cual era
también igual a los ingresos de la
compañía ingresos de la compañía y eso
era igual a los gastos de la compañía
gastos de la compañía más las ganancias
lo cual es igual a los ingresos para el
dueño de la compañía ingresos para el
ocupante de la casa y bueno claro los
ingresos de del dueño terminaron siendo
al menos bueno en este ejemplo fueron
igual los gastos del mismo y lo que
quiero hacer en este vídeo es
generalizar lo pensarlo en términos más
generales hay que extenderlo a una
economía más compleja por ejemplo al
mundo en el que vivimos
y con esto quiero ver una definición más
formal del producto interno bruto y aquí
la tenemos aquí abajito de trabajo esto
estará aquí están les presenta una
definición a la definición mejor dicho
de pib se define como el valor de
mercado de todos los bienes y servicios
finales producidos dentro de un país en
un determinado período
entonces se define como el valor de
mercado de todos de todos lo voy a
subrayar en diferentes colores bienes y
servicios lo mejor en amarillo amarillo
ok de todos los bienes y servicios
producidos dentro de un país dentro de
un país lo pongo con verde en un
determinado periodo entonces podríamos
tener un pib por un mes por un cuarto de
año tres meses o anual un pib anual y
supongo también es posible para 10 años
20 años aunque bueno por lo regular casi
siempre lo pensamos en términos anuales
cuarto de año mes pero por lo regular
casi siempre es anual aunque analicemos
un poco más porque estos términos
pequeños pueden ser bastante
interesantes lo que
analizar la idea de valor de mercado lo
que está diciendo el valor de mercado lo
que dice es bueno necesitamos una manera
de medir lo que producimos y la mejor
manera de pensar es bueno cuánta
ganancia está obteniendo la gente cuánto
está dispuesto la gente a pagar al
mercado y esa es la mejor manera de
medir la ganancia que está obteniendo la
gente por ejemplo si en algún año no sé
si se produjeron aguacate un aguacate
-ha un aguacate en una granja y también
en esa granja se produce en naranjas ok
aquí está la naranja no vemos el pib por
fruta no en lugar vemos el mercado de
valores el mercado de valores lo que
realmente vemos el mercado de valor para
este aguacate supongamos que va a ser de
un dólar un dólar por este paquete y la
naranja no olvidemos la naranja tiene un
valor de mercado de 50 centavos hasta
entonces con producir esta esta fruta el
pib ha aumentado 50 centavos y por el
aguacate el pib ha aumentado un dólar
supongamos que en el año siguiente la
demanda de aguacate es baja y las
personas pagan
por ellos el valor de mercado del
aguacate es ahora de 50 centavos
entonces en el año siguiente aunque el
número o la cantidad de fruta que se
produce sea el mismo que el año previo
ahora de repente la contribución por
aguacates es la misma que la
contribución por naranjas así que todo
realmente depende del valor de mercado
después nos podríamos enfocar en la
palabra todos el valor de mercado de
todos los bienes y servicios
entonces incluiremos a todos los
aguacates naranjas computadoras de pie
dentales llantas carros a tu nombre lo
ahí está todo todo todo así que bueno
también servicios y pasan al doctor o
tienes una ayudante en la casa todo eso
el valor de mercado de todas las cosas a
tomar en cuenta para el pib ahora esto
no incluye algunas cosas esto no incluye
por ejemplo cosas ilegales no eso no si
alguien por ejemplo vende drogas no se
le sigue el rastro aunque hay personas
que creen que si se debería llevar un
rastro bueno un seguimiento más bien
dicho de este mercado negro sin embargo
esto no incluye actividades ilegales y
tampoco se les sigue el rastro
a bienes y servicios producidos en el
hogar y consumidos en el hogar tampoco a
esos un ejemplo supongamos que tú tienes
hijos pero hay un concierto de rock y tú
te quieres ir a roquear como en los
viejos tiempos yeah así que se te ocurre
tú contratas a una niñera y a eso se le
va a considerar o se hace tomar en
cuenta para el pib porque es un servicio
por el cual tú estás pagando en cambio
si tú juegas el papel de niñera si tú
cuidas a tus hijos esto no se tomará en
cuenta para el pib o puedes suponer que
tú inicies un servicio de jardinería y
la chica que te gusta tiene un jardín
súper espantoso horrible así que bueno
le ofreces tu el servicio de jardinería
a la casa de la chica y ella te paga
entonces eso se va a tomar en cuenta en
el pib pero si se llegaran a casar
entonces ya no porque bueno porque ya es
tu casa pero en fin el pib incluya todo
lo que se le puede llevar un seguimiento
todo lo que todo lo que haya un
intercambio de dinero pagos entre
personas por bienes y servicios es a lo
que me refiero algo interesante que yo
encontré algo confuso es esta noción de
bienes y servicios finales
para entenderlo pensemos en cómo se
produce la mezclilla hay que pensar en
un agricultor de algodón para esto hay
una mano de obra que se requiere y
digamos que por esa mano de obra se
cobra cinco dólares por el trabajo cinco
dólares por el trabajo también para
sembrar el algodón
necesitamos tierra entonces hagamos la
renta de tierra y por la tierra nos van
a cobrar supongamos que cuatro dólares
cuatro dólares también otras cosas que
se requieren como electricidad pero
bueno eso no lo vamos a tomar en cuenta
ahorita así que tenemos nuestra ramita
de algodón am aquí la voy a dibujar voy
a dibujar una simple ramita de algodón
ahí está la ramita ok el valor del
mercado del algodón en planta digamos
que es de 10 dólares al algodón así sin
más ni más de 10 dólares es el valor de
mercado
y ya con nuestra rama de algodón podemos
tomar el algodón y convertirlo con más
trabajo digamos que le podríamos
aumentar más mano de obra digamos que 6
dólares más en mano de obra 6 dólares en
trabajo tal vez también se requiera
maquinaria electricidad pero bueno no lo
vamos a tomar en cuenta justo por ahora
y ya he hecho esto combinemos los 10
dólares y esté bien intermediario con
los 6 dólares de la mano de obra 6
dólares de trabajo que puedo producir ya
puedo producir hilo de algodón lo dibujo
aquí mi hilo de algodón y bueno ahora el
mercado de valor de ese hilo de algodón
supongamos que que ahora vale 20 dólares
ajá 20 dólares y bueno puede haber otro
bien intermediario por ejemplo teñir el
algodón pero bueno es uno mejor lo dejo
para después ok
yo puedo tomar ese hilo de algodón que
ahora tiene un valor de mercado de 10
dólares 20 dólares perdón y después
agregar trabajo más trabajo más mano de
obra así que hagamos eso bueno le
podemos poner más mano de obra digamos
que otros 10 dólares en trabajo y de
esta manera crear el valor de 30 dólares
por el tejido de algodón ajá así que
bueno aquí lo voy a dibujar el tejido de
algodón algo así como una tela y luego
puedo tomar mi tejido de algodón más más
trabajo más trabajo supongamos que otros
cinco dólares para trabajar en el
producto y ahora sí a tener la tela se
ha dicho un dólar por teñir la tela y
bueno para tener mis pantalones de
mezclilla bueno los tengo pero ahora sí
ya los tengo que ya los dibujamos aquí
ahora ya tengo mis pantalones de mejía
que yo tanto quería y el valor de
mercado de los servicios para los
pantalones de mezclilla es de 50 dólares
supongamos ahora bien yo hice todo esto
en el período en cuestión lo hago en el
transcurso de todo el año así que
estamos hablando del pib para el año en
curso 2012 entonces ahora la pregunta es
la siguiente
cuál será la contribución para el
producto interno bruto cuál es la
contribución para el pib si no
tuviéramos la palabra final aquí y solo
dijera a todos los bienes y servicios
entonces sumaríamos estos cuatro con
estos 10 con estos 6 con estos 20 y así
todos tendríamos un número muy grande
una contribución gigantesca para el pib
y contar de esta manera sería como
contar ni siquiera el doble será como 4
o 5 veces lo mismo porque todo esto está
haciendo todo este valor está haciendo
ya ha contado en los 50 dólares finales
así que la contribución para el pib en
ella solo vamos a poner el bien final no
más no vamos a incluir todos estos
bienes y servicios intermediarios no
nada de eso sólo diríamos que todo
resulta todo todo resulta que toda esta
cadena resulta en 50 dólares en un
incremento de 50 dólares para el
producto interno bruto en otro vídeo
hablaremos bueno y qué sucede si no
llegamos al producto al punto final aquí
bueno asumiendo que si llegamos a este
punto sólo incluimos el bien final para
el pib
estado de una parte de la definición
producido dentro del país buenos quizás
tú escuchaste alguna vez producto
nacional bruto esa es la diferencia
principal el pib nos dice bueno
supongamos que estamos hablando de eeuu
aquí así que voy a dibujar eeuu aquí
está mi mejor intento más o menos ahí
salió el pib dice bueno mira si se
produjo dentro del país no nos importa
quién lo produjo pudo haber sido
mexicano un canadiense
quizás una empresa china que se yo pero
pero si se produjo dentro del país se
tome en cuenta para el pib ahora bien
supongamos que un americano supongamos
que en américa no viaja cruzando el mar
así que bueno él viaja firma y viaje
cruzando el mar lo vuela a través de él
y bueno él produce algo en otro país eso
no se toma en cuenta para el pib si un
americano es dueño de una compañía en
otro país tampoco se tome en cuenta para
el pib nada de esas cosas cuando nos
enfocamos en la nacionalidad de las
personas eso es el producto nacional
bruto y bueno no te quiero confundir
pero si te quieres enfocar en el
producto nacional bruto entonces te
las ganancias de los ciudadanos del país
ese es el producto nacional bruto el pib
en cambio es una idea sencilla nos está
diciendo lo que se produce dentro del
país sin importar la nacionalidad de
quien lo esté produciendo y vamos a
ignorar por completo la producción de
esa nacionalidad fuera del país